hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
desde que inició la pandemia la
solidaridad ha sido indispensable para
sortear los obstáculos causados por el
cob y 19 muchos se organizaron para dar
a otros y apoyar a los que más lo
necesitan en diferentes formas veamos en
este programa dos iniciativas de
inmigrantes solidarios frente a la
dramática situación que atraviesa
américa latina por el coronavirus los
latinos en italia se movilizaron para
ayudar a sus compatriotas un grupo de
voluntarios ítalo-venezolano se unió
para llevar a cabo un masivo programa de
donaciones de medicinas que son enviadas
a venezuela una iniciativa importante ya
que el país suramericano sufre escasez
de fármacos nuestra corresponsal en
italia natalia mendoza nos cuenta más
esta mañana daniela y su esposo
recorrieron decenas de kilómetros con un
objetivo participar en una iniciativa de
solidaridad hacia el continente
latinoamericano hoy traen medicamentos
para dar en donación tuvimos un luto en
nuestra familia y quedamos con todas
estas medicinas que sobraban pero en
todo caso todavía están buenas y algunas
son inclusive costosas entonces dijimos
que las podríamos donar a esta
asociación por venezuela venezuela
sin perder ni un segundo la donación de
entró en un circuito bien preciso
[Aplausos]
una armada de voluntarios examina y
cataloga cada fármaco aquí convergen
medicinas que llegan de toda italia
donadas por privados o por instituciones
de poco producto eduardo bruni es el
fundador de este proyecto médico
cirujano nacido en venezuela desde hace
cinco años organiza estas colectas una
iniciativa que ha adquirido una
importancia particular desde la
explosión de la pandemia en este país
latinoamericano esto es un antibiótico
que utilizo en este momento de la
situación kobe de venezuela para los
enfermos que tienen primero monya y
sobre infección bacteria en venezuela no
hay antibióticos no se consiguen y los
que se consiguen son de un precio
demasiado exagerado
desde el inicio de la pandemia más de 7
mil kilos de medicinas han sido enviados
gracias a la ayuda de patrocinadores que
financian el envío en el marco de una
campaña internacional de ayuda a
venezuela nosotros hemos canalizado con
la ayuda humanitaria venezuela de europa
vienen los medicamentos
eeuu gracias a la alianza que tenemos
con el programa ayuda humanitaria para
venezuela ellos envían lo que es todo el
presidio sanitario o sea los insumos
médicos la mayoría de los voluntarios
aquí presentes son de origen venezolano
es el caso de maría ángela quien no
escatima esfuerzos cuando se trata de
ayudar a su país aquí nosotros
trabajamos
casi todos los días
nuestro nuestro granito de arena pues
un granito de arena alguna gota en el
mar la gotita en el mar pero que sería
del mar sin esa gota las cajas listas
son selladas y preparadas para el
transporte en pocos días atravesarán el
océano atlántico a borde de un barco de
carga con destino al puerto de la guaira
al norte de caracas en venezuela
y en nueva york' uno de los estados son
más afectados por el cob y 19 en eeuu la
comunidad vive las consecuencias de la
pandemia una familia mexicana decidió
reabrir su negocio de comidas para
brindar alimento gratis a quienes
perdieron sus empleos en medio de la
crisis veamos la historia de una familia
sin documentos que decidió ayudar a
otros
en esta calle del bronx un restaurante
mexicano es comedor para los más
necesitados
natalia méndez pone sobre la mesa los
mejores platos huaqueño en esta zona de
nueva york ahora sirve 650 comidas al
día y un equipo de voluntarios las
reparte entre desempleados y adultos
mayores
así como se recomienda guardar este
distanciamiento y se recomienda poner
mascarillas y lavarse las manos eso es
externo lo que yo estoy pretendiendo al
cocinar éstas estén nutritivas
nutritivas comidas es este sanar un
poquito lo interno natalia una mexicana
que emigró a eeuu sabe de las
consecuencias de la pandemia
ella y su familia la sufrieron tanto
física como económicamente
nuestra gente sin documentos así como
nosotros como yo somos los más
vulnerables en este momento donde no
recibimos ayuda de gobierno no hay un
cheque que te pueda decir para asistir o
un este
algo que sea un pronto auxilio solamente
nos tendremos los unos a los otros como
comunidad y de esa necesidad nace esta
iniciativa que beneficia a cientos de
familias en la gran manzana palabra
mucha gente está sin trabajo no tienen
comida para alimentar a sus hijos así
que esto es una ayuda real para todos el
comedor funciona de martes a viernes y
sus propietarios esperan continuar
sirviendo mole su plato más reconocido a
los que no tienen para su sustento
básico
el restaurante la morada pudo continuar
con sus servicios e implementar la
entrega de comida gratis gracias a ayuda
económica local un banco le negó a
natalia y a su familia un préstamo para
su reapertura por su condición de
indocumentada hasta que inmigrantes de
france24 seguiremos cubriendo la
actualidad de la migración en américa
latina y en el mundo en todas sus
facetas los invitamos a comentar en
nuestras redes sociales con el hashtag
migrantes f24 siga conectado con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]